STEPHANIE WONG: Cat fashion,
photons, and load balancers.
How do they all relate?
YURIY BABENKO: Stay
tuned to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: For many people,
one of the greatest mysteries
in the universe is
how in the world
Google can return billions
of cat image results
in under one second.
So I brought my
friend Yuriy here
to help explain
just how we do that.
YURIY BABENKO:
While the internet
has a whole set of
optimizations to make things
like these searches fast,
Google's global architecture
has its own secret sauce that
allows it to achieve the speed
and accuracy that
you've come to know,
which prompts many customers
and companies to ask
how to leverage that
performance for their own needs.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well, Google
spent the last two decades
building one of the largest,
fastest fiber optic networks
in the world to
support Google Cloud
and Google's own services-- you
know, like YouTube and Gmail.
And that network has grown 15
times in the past six years,
passing 600 trillion
bits per second
across land and through sea,
allowing us to service over
1 billion users a day.
YURIY BABENKO: In
building this network,
Google has had to put in years
of research, some of which
has made it back into the
community as white papers,
which talk about more of
their amazing achievements
in technology.
STEPHANIE WONG: But we're
getting ahead of ourselves.
To understand how big
this technology is,
let's start by getting
small and looking
at how the internet works
from the perspective
of a single photon running
through Google's network.
Let's say we just created our
latest web e-commerce site
on Google Cloud that serves
the latest cat fashion trends.
We have some users in Singapore
who are testing our new site
and send a request
from their device
to purchase cat winter apparel.
YURIY BABENKO: The request
from the user's device
will hit the service
provider first,
which will realize the
destination is a Google server.
It will send it right to the
closest Google front-end server
that it can find.
These GFEs sit at the very edge
of Google's global network,
with multiple
points of presence.
Why?
To allow information to be
served as close to the users
as possible, like Rio de
Janeiro, Zurich, and Singapore.
STEPHANIE WONG: At this point,
Google's technological magic
takes over.
The first thing
the request does is
slam into Google Cloud's
software-defined global load
balancer.
This load balancer is
responsible for distributing
HTTP and HTTP(S) traffic
to back-ends in order
to manage and distribute
load in a scalable way.
In the best scenario, we've
deployed our software onto VMs
running in the Singapore
data center, in which case
the request is handled and the
data is sent back to the user.
YURIY BABENKO: But let's say
the closest back-end instance
group in Singapore
is unavailable,
or maybe we haven't deployed
VMs to this region yet.
The user's request is
seamlessly directed
to other VMs we are
running stationed
in the US-East region.
What is great about the
global L7 load balancer
is that routing to a different
region across the globe
happens without the developer
having to lift a finger.
And configuration is just
a few clicks in the UI.
It gives you a single Anycast IP
that you can point traffic to,
even if the back-ends go down.
STEPHANIE WONG: What lets
the L7 load balancer do
this is the fact that
all of the load balancing
is done in software,
rather than in hardware.
It performs a weighted selection
from the set of back-ends,
skipping any back-ends
that appear unhealthy
or whose connections
are saturated.
This is called the waterfall
by region algorithm,
and we'll have an
in-depth episode
on this on our other series,
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Traffic is proxied
through these GFEs, which
forwards the query to
the selected back-end
running our cat web server.
YURIY BABENKO: Now, in our
scenario of a user in Singapore
requesting data from
a VM in US-East,
the GFEs send the request across
a subsea fiber optical cable
from APAC to the
US, which connects
various operational
regions of Google Cloud.
These fiber networks
connect Cloud regions
across land with
thousands of kilometers.
You've probably passed them
and never even noticed.
They are underground, along
railroad tracks, across
[INAUDIBLE],, or even
across mountain ranges.
And if you're wondering
about the speed,
photons travel at [INAUDIBLE]
of the speed of light in fiber.
And with that speed,
our photons can
carry over 2,000,000 photos
and 8,000 YouTube videos
every second across our network.
STEPHANIE WONG: Bear with
me on what happens next.
That Anycast IP the
L7 load balancer
has comes with an
associated forwarding
rule, which will then direct
traffic to a target proxy.
Here, the target proxy
terminates the client session.
It has configurations
for a URL map,
like host and path rules,
which then routes the traffic
to the correct back-end service
on VMs in the US-East region.
YURIY BABENKO: The
back-end servers
check each back-end's
capacity and health
and sends traffic to the most
available and healthy back-end.
It then sends the
shopping data back.
The GFE caches the response
and forwards it to the user.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
this, my friends,
is how you can optimize for
latency by choosing from Google
Cloud's globally
extensive regions
that are closest
to your users, even
when back-ends are
overloaded or unhealthy.
Or you can use Google Cloud
content delivery network
to leverage our
load-balancing and cache
content closer to your users.
YURIY BABENKO: But let's
go back for a second.
We would be remiss
if we didn't discuss
in a bit more
detail what happens
as the content is sent back to
the user from the back-ends.
As the response is served
back to the GFE from the VM,
photons are sent
from our servers,
which are connected to optical
transmission equipment.
These use infrared lasers
to transmit signals
through the fiber network.
A typical cable would have
hundreds of optical fibers,
each made of a glass, with a
diameter of just a human hair.
And they can transmit signals
with terabytes capacity.
Then the photons leave the
Google data center's fibers
that are bundled in an
outside plant cable.
STEPHANIE WONG: But we
inevitably face a problem.
As photons travel down
fiber optic cables,
their intensity diminishes,
called attenuation.
For example, in one of
Google's research papers,
they demonstrated what happens
when optical signals travel
through 3,200 kilometers.
Looking at the graph, you can
see that the relative power
level of the signal decreased.
So how do photons
make it all the way
between regions which are
thousands of kilometers apart?
YURIY BABENKO: To
combat attenuation,
we place optical amplifiers
along our cables,
with hundreds of
them on the route.
Amplifiers increase a
signal over long distances,
so our photon on can
make it to a destination.
STEPHANIE WONG: The
journey of the photon
finally ends back in Singapore.
It traveled along fiber
laid underground and strung
through the air,
getting amplified
along the way, all of which
happen in just milliseconds.
Our fiber networks now connect
to Google Cloud regions
across five continents.
Over the past 10 years,
through a combination
of buying and leasing, Google
has fiber all around the world.
But this is only the beginning.
There is so much
more in development
to support our
future cloud regions.
YURIY BABENKO: In fact,
you can automatically
take advantage of these
by using the Premium Tier
network to access Google's
own global private network,
avoiding suboptimal
internet path.
Check out the link
below to learn more.
STEPHANIE WONG: Like
this video if you
want more content like this.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]